نعم محمد كما نتابع هنا في هذه الصور التي
تشاهدونه مباشره على شاشه العربيه عمليات
الانقاذ في معظم المواقع في اضنه تقريبا
تشارف على الانتهاء يعني ساعات قليله مثلا
في هذا الموقع الذي نتواجد فيه وتكتمل
عمليات
البحث بين الركام وتحت الانقاض قبل قليل
يعني في الساعه الماضيه انتشلوا جثتين من
او انتشرت فرق الانقاذ جثتين من هذا
الموقع وتم نقلهما بالسياره دفن الموتى او
نقل الموتى الى مكان اخر حيث يصار الى
دفنهم بطريقه رسميه بعد حضور ذويهم طبعا
الان يعني او في ساعات المساء الماضيه
انتشر الجيش التركي هنا في او دخل الجيش
التركي الى هذا الموقع ليشرك بشكل رسمي
على اتمام عمليات البحث
طبعا يعني
مع الاسف الامان تتضاءل نحن نقترب من
اليوم من دخول اليوم الخامس باقي ساعه
واحده وينتهي تنتهي اربعه ايام على وقوع
هذه الكارثه وسندخل في اليوم الخامس فرص
الوصول الى ناجين يعني تبدو ضئيله لكن مع
ذلك هناك دائما امال يعني يعني اليوم
الماضي يوم الخميس صباح الخميس
استطاعوا الوصول الى احد الاشخاص الذي كان
على قيد الحياه هذا الموضوع اعطى دفع
معنويه اضافيه لفرق الانقاذ للتعامل او
لتكثيف البحث خلال ساعات يوم الخميس
واحضروا اضافه للفرق التي مختصه التي كانت
هنا والتي كان معها كلاب مدربه ايضا
احضروا فريق خاص معه كاميرات مراقبه
حراريه ورصدوا الموقع من اكثر من جهه
واكثر من منطقه وحاولوا
وصول الى اشخاص على قيد الحياه لكن مع
الاسف انقضى يوم الخميس دون الوصول الى
شخص اخر على قيد الحياه وقبل ساعه من الان
انتشروا جثتين من هنا اعمال البحث
الاعمال البحث ما زالت تستمر حتى انها
تقريبا هذا المبنى ازيلت حوالي 80 الى 90%
من الانقاذ التي كانت موجوده في هذا
الموقع هذا المبنى كان مؤلف من 14 طابقا
حتى يوم امس يعني احد رجال الانقاذ اخبرنا
بانهم كانوا يتوقعون ان منذ اليوم الاول
للزلزال كانوا يتوقعون وجود حوالي 80 شخص
عالقين تحت الانقاض هذا احد يعني ايضا شخص
اخر من فرق الانقاذ اخبرنا ان معظم الجثث
او حتى الاحياء الذين تم العثور عليهم
كانوا في منطقه السلالم او الدرج اثناء
محاولتهم الهروب من المبنى عند حدوث
الزلزال انهار المبنى بالكامل لذلك معظم
الجثث تم انتشالها من تلك المنطقه حتى
الناجين تم العثور عليهم في بعض
او تحت بعض
الجدار الاسمنتي الذي كان يحمي الدرج او
السلالم وتمكنوا من الصمود في تلك المواقع
الى ان وصلت اليهم فرق على الانقاذ